welcome to this video against Kolia
corner culiacan probably screwing this
up right this pronunciation ok so we
have an English no we gotta Hedgehog
Hedgehog let's see y'all I always not
always but almost all the time play this
set up with this be three line and then
with the trade yeah this is always I
think rather comfortable position for
white especially now that I got it f4 f4
Queen f3 roop t1r the move that I would
like to play um looks like our managed
he's not playing okay we're here it's
not playing a six was what I was trying
to say but some at some point they're
there every is night to to be five so he
has to play it at it some at some point
really okay i'm trying to get active on
the kingside this set up with III s only
deceptively modest wide really wants to
do something on the King side with the
g4 and h4 those advances but III give
some more stability to the center in a
way as there is no quality for that can
be attacked and here we go
so let's consider how to to proceed um
yes I f5 allows 925 this is probably a
wrong idea I should I must I must do am
one thing really make sure that b5 and
d5 is not really playable and the
Knights on c3 and if I do a good job at
the moment what I also must check is be
for trying to just trap the night it's
only has be 7 as a square and it's very
important to keep that in mind that at
some point maybe even before as possible
h4 was just a strengthening with
improving the structure but here I can
actually push further and open open the
age file like that why not aha it seems
that is a bit afraid on under the hood
on the Kings side let's see okay please
recapturing with the f porn that's an
interesting decision okay should I am
really do even more on the H file look
edge for this cat of moves on or is this
a wrong approach hmm interesting the d6
pond is quite weak now I wonder that
maybe should switch to something
entirely different play play let's say
Queen to c6 what is this response to
Quincy six if I go for a queen traitor
it's not bad actually I believe
it's our time at the end to defend the
six of you trade screens now and where
is he going actually now maybe he can
move Queen da doc we'd be eight keeping
the six keeping b6 protected yes that's
possible but I thought I could take and
if I now retreat it and just the tech t
six how is he going to to defend it at
least in the in the the short term 92
are I wonder 92 RF three maybe f3 yo
what is sick so my idea is to just
continue looked it to look too young
okay let's see I actually could play 95
and getting the bishop here it's not bad
really bad because I have this idea to
play Bishop f6 immediately and of course
rock t5 is also in the mix it cannot
really prevent both it can play a book
King f7 but I have Bishop f6 attacking
the rook and then I can take should be
quite good well quite good is probably a
huge understatement but I think blacks
bus city right went what does this move
actually I'm King f7 I can also just
take a take a phage this is easier I
don't really want it you don't want to
take this bed night here but it's just
so easy taking take d5 and that's it the
d6 some porn is weak on on top of all of
it
yes yawa here I need to take g5 ride
he's got nights if near death does not
even have 93 so I can just take that ok
so here is there anything better than
just retreating if i go to be true we
might play be five but that's 92 which
is a pretty good response ok 92 bishop
f6 is the point and here i thought maybe
before even ok i can i can play it much
simpler just like that detect the attack
it with the king black risen yeah yeah
just he must move now in bishop f six
wins wins the house and that was quite
nice looked like nice victoria somehow
yeah well this is a line that i really
have quite a lot of experience in this
was a really pretty pretty good version
of it so white has the space advantage
and it's not so clear what black is
doing maybe he needs to do something
drastic like be 50 yeah it's tough to
tough to the tough to tell um you can
also consider to play Queen to be seven
exchanging Queens but it's not much fun
to play you simply don't get be five in
d5 in here so easily here this already
looks looks like a very nice position
not sure about quincy success was an
interesting try maybe but not so sure
about the objective merit
the way it it was played I think was
quite nice uh-huh here the computer
suggests an improvement playing d5
interesting hey but it's also quite
nicely this is the computers main line
which is also just a very good position
for white this fantastic diagonal and
space advantage better structure yeah
here 95 was already already yeah quite
good yeah okay this is just the normal
looking movement check this is Sam a
disaster the real issue is in my my
point of view sm that starting around
here black and try for an improvement
here for example equation 7 is probably
the better choice it pretty much forces
Queenie of three I don't want to go King
g1 or something and then you get this
this end game in a better version the
end game that i showed the b-form that's
simply a somewhat better version of it
or you can avoid the move order d6 all
together and be a bit more flexible here
not that d6 is a bad move but once I
have committed to be three it's an
interesting question if you should means
that for example you can play like that
if I try the exact same thing there is
this move available which will trade
this important d4 Knight and this also
should be quite ok for black so this is
not a not a super convincing line for
why that refutes the head refutes the
head shot or something it's just a good
practical practical weapon but if black
knows what what's happe
it should be ok alright thanks for
watching